[Music]
today children everywhere are making
preparations happy holiday news position
everyone also the bleak scenes currently
on screen maybe subconsciously read this
as children prepare for satan and
honestly that's the lost fred astaire
movie i think we'd all rather be
watching legions of junior citizens are
making monumental efforts not to cry and
not to bow that's it kids let's bottle
up those emotions and bury them deeper
you won't be able to appreciate all the
material things you've asked santa to
bring you ah the true meaning of
christmas
questions
like you take this one how would sd know
that this letter contains a question
before he reads it has he opened it
already and placed it back in the
envelope and is now acting like a
know-it-all to the children who are
watching what an [ __ ] also opening
someone else's mail
my turn my turn is that how the letter
started calm down kid everyone gets a
turn with santa and by the end of the
show this will not be as exciting i
promise you
i can answer all your questions because
i know everything about santa bragging
about being a stalker
to fill on christmas day i challenge
that claim sir if the parameters for
receiving christmas presents are no
pouting crying and generally
quote-unquote being good most kids would
be struck from santa's list by midday on
january 1st at the very latest this
[ __ ] made damn sure he'd have the
easiest job thinkable
you better not cry
you know it i know it the whole damn
world knows it this song is creepy as
balls and intentionally so forget
festive cheer this is all about giving
parents a stick to beat their kids into
good behavior with as soon as the sugar
high from halloween has brought them
crashing back down to earth in the
second the christmas decorations are
down we transition into the threat of
the easter bunny with holding chocolaty
goodness followed by the promise that
best behavior will be rewarded by a trip
to disneyland or some such to cover the
summer months and the real smart parents
out there even made sure to land a
birthday sometime in september to
provide one final carrot before we roll
back into halloween again you'd think
it'd be easier to teach kids to do the
right thing regardless of extrinsic
motivators
you would be wrong no wonder santa is up
against it this [ __ ] is frolicking in
the snow with all of his mail instead of
calling aaa to get his van fixed every
year thousands of kids end up
disappointed at christmas because this
is how they've been taught to address
their mail to santa guess i won't be
needing this anymore you mean santa was
once
a baby of course and spoiler alert this
show does not explain how he somehow
became an immortal godlike judge of
mankind's children in their worthiness
of toys
a mean old grouch of a fellow who was
known as burgermeister meisterberger
looks like these writers went to the if
in doubt make it german school of bad
guy creation please sir take care of my
child my sister burger obviously has a
reputation for being a complete grouch
so why would mama claws think he would
make a suitable father to her child get
that brad out of here
imagine being so evil that you have a
minion on hand to dim the lights
whenever you do something evil to
accentuate just how evil you are oh dude
come back come back asking a runaway
sleigh to return so just to recap a bit
here wind lifted up an infant in a slate
checked it into a tree animals buried it
beneath sticks then kidnapped it into
the bitter cold of an all-but abandoned
elf town and somehow claws survived this
i'm once again bemused and befuddled by
the north pole postal service how is
anyone supposed to know if there's mail
in this mailbox if the [ __ ] come get
me flag is only painted on wiggle my
ears and tickle my toes he thinks i see
a baby's nose it's more than a nose
there's a whole baby attached to it this
becomes extremely dark when you think
about the frequency with which the
kringle family must receive the severed
noses of babies for the reaction to be
this cute rhyme instead of holy sh some
sick bastard sent us the nose of a
[ __ ] baby the most cynical part of
this entire production is that no one is
supporting the infant's neck as they
pass the baby around the group i like
babies people who like babies a baby but
a splendid idea how is the baby an idea
to compliment the kid was abandoned on
their stoop left by woodland creatures
escaping a warlock or some
what a splendid accident would be more
appropriate
he shall live with us and sleep with us
and drink warm cocoa with us okay we
know that this baby has been abandoned
but the elves don't shouldn't their
first step be to attempt to reunite him
with his actual family we should call
him chris chris kringle yeah let's admit
a whole new name because the name on his
necklace that clearly says claws make
toys that's right this is the riveting
tale of child labor that ends in a man
who cannot let the dying tradition of
making toys by hand go so he confuses
children into loving him after forcing
toys on them and we like this story the
only problem was there were no children
to give them to meaning for years these
elves were making toys and then what
burning them in a ritual fire giving
them to the woodland creatures piling
them outside for no reason just
stop making toys remember summertime was
on the other side of the mountain the
whispering winds and also remember that
in this story there were no other
children anywhere in the world but
somber town
applauding your own song i realize we
live in a strange universe where
reindeer will fly but how is chris
running up a tree
the fred astaire raider wants us to
believe that santa got his famous laugh
by imitating seals and that is some
[ __ ] sir i'm a man now tanta i can
take those toys across the mountain of
the whispering winds but what about
being a man makes someone capable of
traversing dangerous landscapes for a
delivery how about i've trained for
years as an athlete and apprentice with
a world-renowned cartographer i am now
ready to fearlessly navigate if only one
of my dollies could be held tight by a
little girl or boy
well
what is a penguin doing here what sort
of question is this chris literally
learned to ho ho ho from a seal but a
penguin is a bridge too far also i'm so
glad we're about to spend a full two
minutes introducing this penguin who
will be nothing more than a honking
burden for this entire story i shall get
him when he returns
he's got to cross my mountain on the way
home to be clear chris heard the warning
and turned to walk away and the warlock
gave up so from here to here is the
official dangerous mountain that has
prevented anyone from getting down the
mountain to deliver children's toys i
see not only was this toy not on the
steps moments earlier as we can clearly
all see but none of burgermeister
meisterburgerman saw this brightly
colored toy on the steps of city hall
and removed it before mr grumpy ran into
it i hate toys and toys hate me and we
hate fakers you have a broken bone lay
down the lyrics say to wash the face of
the clown but instead they acid melt it
70s really knew how to [ __ ] up a kid is
he about to [ __ ] on that book what is
happening here anyone found with a toy
in his possession good news if you're
not a boy you're in the clear these
terrifying horse gums
the townspeople didn't know what to make
of chris well of course not he's
apparently barking like a seal if you
sit on my lap today a kiss a toy is the
price you'll pay
lyrics that don't age well i used to be
able to do all kinds of tricks
that'll be just the one trick then we'll
never find him in there because finding
a man in a bright red suit lugging a
massive sack of toys through the snow is
really hard to do changing from bad to
good's as easy as
taking your first step the winner
warlock is having an existential crisis
about whether or not his heart only has
the capacity for evil and kris kringle
thinks this song about walking is going
to help and it does
and soon you'll be walking out the door
i love a moment when the lyrics make
sense for what is happening on screen
but i can't understand why there is a
door here not only can you walk around
the side easily but there's nothing on
the opposite side of the door that would
constitute a reason for the door to
exist in the first place you see
the burger meister destroyed the ones
you brought you tell those youngins
there'll be plenty of toys great but
what's the stop burgermeister from
collecting all the toys up and burning
them again no crying or pouting all
right why can't kids cry or pout sure
it's annoying when their tiny brains
think that pouting or crying about an
inside out sock during family dinner is
the most important thing but who [ __ ]
cares take a moment and help the kid
understand their sock isn't the end of
the world don't shame them for having
emotions and then reward them for
holding that [ __ ] in for presents oh
thank you chris for what for being so
kind for being kind this grown man just
said he'd be peeping on sleeping
children i guess they figured it made
sense to move the source of supply close
to the demand yes that makes perfect
sense so why didn't they set themselves
up near somber town on the first [ __ ]
place why did the kringles choose to put
a [ __ ] winter warlock guarded
mountain between them and the only
children they have access to why didn't
gandalf just fly the hobbits to mordor
and that's how he started going down
chimneys sure i can believe a penguin
told a man to climb on a roof and to
send a chimney to give contraband to a
miner but this does not explain how a
grown man fits a sack of toys down the
chimney or why he takes the whole sack
in the first place i will set a trap for
that bottle some kringle why wasn't this
the plan to start with dealing with the
presents instead of the person leaving
them is as pointless as cleaning up
[ __ ] footprints every morning without
boarding up the fireplace admittedly
that ending is probably a touch dark for
this tales target audience it was too
late
chris had already left with his toys and
really children chris's arrest was her
fault because she chose to walk through
the woods rather than send a message by
bird which is why we encourage
forgetting about mrs claus all together
every christmas season alas
i've been
disenchanted
i have no more powers but how somehow we
know the seals gave santa his ho ho ho
but we aren't given a single line of
explanation as to how discount
dumbledore here lost his powers is it
because he got a heart see this is why
we remain heartless bastards people oh i
tell you things didn't look good it
would look even worse if they'd arrested
all of the people aiding the criminal
kris kringle rather than leave someone
free who can continue the plot line wait
is kringle going down chimney's head
first that or he must be turning around
mid descent to be able to crawl out head
first like this tv movie has time for
this acid-induced snow white rip-off
fever dream of a musical number well
jessica realized the first thing she had
to do was set chris and the others free
odd considering that after she ate
peyote and found herself on a spirit
walk she's sang about having no plan so
you know coming out of the drug induced
revelation with a plan is surprising to
me the tiny stubs of a hundred are so
magic candles 100 there are eight on the
ground here and i have doubts on how
they fit into winter's cloak before the
total was 100. magic feed corn well it's
of no use to us it can't dissolve prison
walls all i could do is make
reindeer fly would you look at that he
just so happens to have in his
possession an item that is totally
completely entirely 100 categorically
useless except in this one very specific
instance phew and don't forget
no that that's another story apparently
squeezing in this rudolph reference was
deemed more important to the plot than
explaining how the flying reindeer in
any way helped to break moody merlin out
of his prison cell i still have a little
magic
oh i'm not such a loser after all i'm
going to make all of us feel [ __ ]
special that's how santa's reindeer
started to fly that's just the way it
happened citation needed it was that
name jessica agreed to take
as his merry skipmus what kind of
sadistic maniac decorated these trees
the tinsel is just limpy hanging from
the top there's altogether too much fake
snow and these two over here don't even
have a star creepy angel at the top i
can hardly keep up with the orders
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to limit my
journeys to
a one a year how is that gonna help how
can an increased demand be solved by
reducing how often you deliver this
right here is exactly how bezos stole
christmas how goes it mr warlock
winter please claus has an encyclopedic
knowledge of every child's name and
address throughout the entire world but
after decades of friendship the bearded
bastard still can't get winner's name
right christmas is a bother the noise
the crowds i really wish it were
outlawed did you find yourself getting
caught up in the heartwarming tale of mr
and mrs santa claus falling in love and
bringing joy to children everywhere
don't worry because the movie decides to
use its closing minutes to bring us
crashing back to reality to remind us of
the true meaning of christmas grumpy
businessman and manic consumerism
cassatta can still look into his magic
snowball and see just what you're up to
good that creepy [ __ ] can see me do
this
and this
and this
santa claus is coming
to town
roll commercials
[Music]
oh what's in the box
well hello there
general kenobi
bring out your name
bring out today
give me all your toys
[Music]
look at them go i bet you know their
names dash against the brands of vixen
comic cubic donovan dasha dancer
[Music]
i'm having a good time bye
come on now tear this ship apart until
you found those plans and bring me the
passengers i want them alive this is all
some kind of whacked-out conspiracy
we're going to the wide-open spaces of
antarctica
you're you're just a little creepy
creepy
[Music]